lala minec tome a es la extracción
quirúrgica de una parte de la vértebra
conocida como la lámina la columna
vertebral o espina dorsal está compuesta
por 24 vértebras cada vértebra tiene dos
láminas que unidas forman el techo del
canal raquídeo la lámina protege la
médula espinal en las regiones del
cuello y de la espalda en la parte
inferior de la espalda donde termina la
médula espinal
la lámina protege el gran racimo de
nervios que se conoce como cauda equina
y las raíces nerviosas rack ideas la
compresión de las raíces nerviosas puede
deberse a los osteofitos producidos por
la artritis las hernias de disco que
comprimen la raíz del nervio o con menor
frecuencia los tumores óseos de las
vértebras la lámina tome a alivio el
dolor de espalda y de las piernas
causado por esta compresión de las
raíces nerviosas al extirpar la lámina
en forma total o parcial esto alivia de
inmediato a la presión sobre la raíz
nerviosa ante la presencia de una hernia
de disco por lo general el médico
realizará una discectomía a través de la
cual se elimina directamente la causa de
la compresión la lámina tome a se puede
realizar en las vértebra
en la parte inferior de la espalda
llamadas vértebras lumbares o bien en
las de la zona del cuello llamadas
vértebras cervicales la micro lámina que
tome ahí la microdisectomía son
procedimientos que se realizan con la
ayuda de un microscopio al llegar al
hospital se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y es posible que se le
coloque un catéter en la vejiga para
drenar la orina momentos antes de la
cirugía se le administrara anestesia
general o rachidia la anestesia raquídea
se inyecta dentro de un saco que rodea
la médula espinal y adormece el área en
la que el médico va a trabajar
mikel administra anestesia raquídea
estará despierto durante el
procedimiento pero no sentirá nada en la
mitad inferior de su cuerpo
la lámina y tommy a lleva entre una y
tres horas durante el procedimiento se
le colocará en posición decúbito ventral
boca abajo o lateral de costado
el cirujano comenzará realizando una
pequeña incisión sobre la columna las
pinzas se utilizan para separar la grasa
y los músculos de la lámina con un
taladro especial para huesos
el cirujano cortará la lámina para poder
ver el canal raquídeo y ubicar la causa
de la compresión nerviosa si lo que
causa la compresión es una hernia discal
el médico realizará una discectomía para
retirar la protuberancia del disco para
completar el procedimiento se suturar a
los tejidos profundos y la incisión de
la espalda
después de la cirugía se le trasladará a
la sala de recuperación para
monitorearlo las enfermeras comprobarán
de manera regular sus signos vitales y
la fuerza de la pierna del lado donde se
le realizó la cirugía para asegurarse de
que el nervio no haya sufrido ninguna
lesión grave se le recomendará
levantarse y caminar tan pronto como se
sienta bien si se le insertó un catéter
antes de la cirugía el mismo se le
retirará antes de abandonar al hospital
si la disectomía no presenta
complicaciones es probable que le den de
alta al día siguiente de la intervención
las lámina y tommy as que se realicen
por otros motivos pueden requerir
internamientos más prolongados